I was with a woman who already had a
child
we had a child together but what was
very
um very apparent to me within that
relationship was that I was not allowed
to discipline this child the way I could
discipline my own child right because a
child still had the father in their life
the father would have something to say
about it if I disciplined the child in a
certain way and so I
there's a lot of men out here saying
that they wouldn't get with a woman a
lot of men saying they wouldn't get with
a woman who already has a child because
you get a lot of the benefits sorry you
don't get all of the benefits of being a
father right but you have the
responsibility as a father so it's like
what is the incentive for men to
actually get with women who actually
already have children when you know that
at some point in time you are going to
be reminded that that child ain't yours